hey guys
welcome to blue prism full course in
this full course we will cover the core
topics of blueprism
blueprism is a well-known robotic
process automation tool
blueprism is a global leader in
intelligent enterprise automation
transforming the way employees work by
making it simple for individuals to
automate
operations blueprism helps enterprises
improve operational efficiency and
agility
here is a list of topics covered in this
blueprism full course
we will first begin with what is blue
prism wherein we will understand blue
prism features components and
applications
then we will go through blue prism
installation in which we will install
the blue prism learning edition software
proceeding further we will look at the
blue prism tutorial
in which we will explore the blue prism
software and understand the blueprism
user interface
and finally we will look at blueprism
interview questions
which will help you crack blue prism
interview at ease i am sure you are
excited to begin with full course
but before we begin make sure you have
subscribed to our youtube channel and
clicked on the bell icon
so you never miss an update from simply
learn so without wasting any further
time
let's get started what is blue prism
blue prism is a software that develops
enterprise robotic process
automation allowing businesses to
automate complex
end-to-end operations blueprism
developed the virtual workforce platform
concept
and works on an enterprise robotic
process automation platform
that is strong highly scalable secure
and reliable blueprism software
complements
standard it solutions by utilizing an
agile virtual workforce
that follows rule-based business
processes and interacts with the system
in the same way that users do
blueprism's rpa software solution
automates tasks that would otherwise be
carried out manually
by humans or through major customization
of current id systems
resulting in a higher level of
automation with significantly lesser
investment and faster deployment
features of blue prism
intelligent execution technology
organizations can instruct the
autonomous engine
on process priorities feed amounts of
work
and leave it to run without human
involvement responding to systems
business scenarios and change in
priorities
robots like humans can be used to do
tasks based on sla
volume and priority as well as adjust
and change robot allocation
dynamically without human intervention
high security a software robot securely
locks into an application
and manipulates the presentation layer
in the same manner as a person would
but in a controlled non-invasive
environment
ensuring that the application's
integrity is never affected
on premises or in the cloud on-premises
or hybrid enterprise deployment
provisioned in a public or private cloud
the robots are existing and running any
operation
set in blue prism can be conducted on
any number of robots in the virtual
workforce
built on microsoft sql server blue prism
is built on microsoft.net framework
it is technology flexible working across
different platforms
and technologies such as mainframe
windows app
wpf app java sap custom
apps citrix thick client thin client web
services
and so on scalability
blue prism is object oriented allowing
for rapid scalability
by utilizing reusable items and
libraries
analytics and reporting blueprism
provides
high quality data that can be used to
produce relevant
bi and mi reporting as well as providing
in-line process
statistics and real-time operational
insights
by capturing each step
work use work use provides a cue-centric
approach
for dynamically controlling the number
of resources or robots
operating against a given queue at any
given time
allowing for the greatest flexibility in
the adjusting the number of resources
assigned to collaborately work items
architecture of blue prism
blueprism technology is backed by a
comprehensive methodology for rapid
business process development
deployment and operational support
allowing for a whole business process
cycle
to be completed within the same
environment
this diagram depicts the architectural
components of blue prism deployment
including all aspects to enable
governance security
and control as well as the inherent
flexibility to support operational
agility and self-service
monitoring and referrals technically
service monitoring and business-owned
referral management for work items
requiring additional manual steps
operational and methodologies a
comprehensive framework for implementing
blue prism methodologies
including analysis design development
and implementation i.t
governance the principles that underpin
best practice in the process selection
change management
and release procedures operational
configuration
ownership of blueprism product for
operational configuration
testing and execution
roles and responsibilities within the
methodology there are clear
developed roles for managing and
implementing the many aspects of ongoing
agility
security functions of security products
infrastructure
and methodology that provides secure and
compliant
implementation support and hosting
a robust scalable infrastructure that
allows for rapid deployment
and expansion based on business
requirements
components of blue prism
object studio object studio allows
business
users or iit professionals to construct
reusable blue prism
objects as the building blocks for the
business process
by modeling current applications and
training blue prism as a robotic user
object studio is the design canvas on
which the blue prism robot is programmed
to conduct the fundamental system
activities that serve as the foundation
of process
the presentation layer which provides a
library of elements
with which to operate quickly models and
validates the target desktop application
process studio process studio provides a
similar interface to object studio
and allows you to sequence and test
business logic
control loops variables and object calls
in a visible business flow
studio allows the company or it to
design
build edit and test processes made out
of reusable blue prism elements
as the library of business object grows
actions can be scheduled and controlled
in the process layer
the top tire of the blue prism
architecture
process in blue prism are comparable to
software procedures
in that they can invoke objects and
operations in order to run applications
automate rule-based process and business
logic
control room control room allows
business or iit services to schedule
perform and control processes blue prism
platform administrators can use the blue
prism control room interface
to monitor and review the status of
interconnected runtime resources
in the production environment the
interface
also allows for manual process start and
stop automated process schedule setting
and extensive management information and
dig downs into blue prism task queues
applications of blue prism
blueprism's rba software is used in the
following process types
rule-based processing using digital
structured inputs
such as credit card activation or fraud
detection
transactional processing that is
repeated such as
sim swaps or invoice processing
transaction quantities that are high
such as
billing or new handset order processing
issues with process adherence quality
such as policy renewals
or policy migrations
complex mission critical procedures such
as pension redemptions
and financial reconciliation
changes in demand or backlogs such as
new product launches
it is used in hr onboarding or the
introduction of new online product
where no integration exists
benefits of blue prism
the first benefit is automation speed
days and weeks to automate processes in
blue prism that would take
months and years to automate using the
standard automation methodologies
less expense robots are programmed with
the business rules of repetitive
duties and deployed to drive existing
applications
eliminating the requirement for costly
integration and process redesign
expertise
improved performance a small specialist
ability
within the iit department collaborates
with the robotic workforce
to train them manage referrals and
continuously enhance the robot's
operational performance
secure the robotic automation platform
is secure
audited and governed with a governance
i.t corridor
the usage of software robots invariably
increases
compliance with applicable data
standards
confidentiality and the speed and
accuracy of record keeping
scalable because the software robots
operate in a virtualized environment
they can be rapidly scaled up and down
based on the demand
companies using blue prism
google microsoft ibm
ey kpmg
accenture siemens and jaguar
salary trends
in india the average salary for rpa
developer
blue prism is 6 lakhs 4046 rupees per
year
and the salary ranges from 5 black 1028
rupees
to 9 lakhs 90 000 rupees
in united states the average salary for
a blue prism developer
eight is 88 seventy five dollars and the
salary ranges from
sixty thousand three sixty two dollars
to one thirty thousand
eight hundred and fifty seven dollars in
this video we will learn about
installation of blue prism go to the
browser
and browse to blue prism portal
go to the blue prism portal login page
if you're new user go to sign up here
and enter the email address username
password
and confirm the password scroll down and
enter the first name
last name job title country
and fill all the required details and
solve this math question
and then create a new account
since i already have an account i'll
click on login
and i'll login
so once once you sign up you will
receive an
email go to your email id and
check the email go to your inbox
and check the email which you have
received and open the email
and you will receive a link click on
that link
click on the link then go to the product
go to blueprint of enterprise
and go to the edition which you want to
download so we'll download the learning
edition
so click on the learning edition and
then click on
download 64-bit
so here you can see that the download
has been started
so it's getting downloaded so when this
software is getting downloaded you will
receive an license key
so go to your inbox and go to your spam
folder
and check for the license key so here
you can see
we have received this license key
so this is this attachment this is the
license key
so download this license key
and here you can see the steps have been
written
how you need to download so once this is
downloaded
we'll open it when it is done
so now we are installing the blue prism
software
so first click on get started
the next license agreement check the
license agreement and
click on next then check the location
this is the default location
if you want to change your location you
can change we'll keep it as default and
click on
install here you go the
blueprism software is getting installed
so we have installed a blue prism on our
machine
click on finish and launch bluepriser
so the blue prism is getting launched
and the next step is we need to create
the password so create a password the
login password which you
want create your own password after
creating the password click on save and
continue
and then click on next building
databases
once the database is complete
installation is done
click on next blueprism learning edition
opens
enter the admin username and password
which we created in the previous steps
enter the username admin and password
click on sign in using blue prism
credentials so enter the path to the
license key
go to your email id and go to your spam
folders
in which you have received the license
key so browse there
and select the license key then click on
next
you have successfully activated the blue
prism license key
then click on next to launch the
application so the blueprism application
is successfully launched
click on next so it will give an
overview about the home page
and the studio control room
and digital exchange go through the
overview
and that's it you have successfully
installed the blue prism learning
edition
blue prism user interface there are six
types of tabs in blue prism
that is home studio control analytics
releases and system
the home page includes many charts that
provide information on the blueprism
database
the workforce availability metric
displays the runtime resources
that we are utilizing the amount of
queues
and automation in the database is shown
by total automation
queue volumes now displays queue volumes
based on the statuses
and largest database table displays the
blueprism database
largest tables
studio blueprism studio is a critical
component
through which we built actual automation
actions with studio
we can automate a process build a
process using flow
add logic calculations and intelligence
without writing any code
drag in actions calculations loops and
more
in studio we can connect the blocks in
preferred order
use smart skills from digital exchange
digital exchange is where we can find
ready-made skills to enhance
the automation with machine learning ai
language translation and many more
the studios are divided into two
categories object studio and
process studio control room control room
assigns the process
to digital workers user can quickly
start a process
by dragging it on to a resource the
control room is the key administrative
point in blue prism
where we can handle the control
monitoring execution
and scheduling of process executions on
dispersed robots
analytics blueprism analytics is a
module
that allows you to see data graphically
in the form of charts
such as pi column gauge and line
releases
the release manager is used to manage
configuration package
import and export between multiple blue
prism settings
system administrators use the system tab
to manage users
let's look at some of the blue prism
components
some of the blue prism components are
process studio
object studio application modeler
exception handling
and work use
a blue prism process is created as a
diagram that looks much like a common
business flow diagram
we can call from the process studio if
the page is published
for development and testing we use
process studio
process studio has only main page
object studio
object studio is mostly used to create
objects
we have several type of activities
within the object
which are as follows that is the modular
application
to spy the elements initialize page and
cleanup page
the next component is application
modular
the application modeler is used to spy
on apps spying is the process of
identifying the elements in the
applications
we have four different types of spying
modes that is
win32 mode html mode
accessibility mode and region mode
the next component is exception handling
the managing of exceptions in unattended
automation
is defined as exception handling it
ensures that faults can be automatically
fixed if possible
or that they are easily identified and
repairable by system administrators
or they can be forwarded for human
completion if necessary
exception handling success is determined
by how well it is implemented throughout
the development
exception handling is a critical part of
any blue prism solution
an exception is a problem that arises
during the execution of a process
when errors are encountered in blue
prism it generates exceptions
exception handling stages
exception handling can be achieved using
resume
recover and exception stage
in resume stage it ends a block for
handling exceptions
in recovery it begins a block for
handling exceptions
in exception stage explicit arises an
exception in the execution of process
or an object the different types of
exception are
internal exception system exception and
business exceptions
internal exceptions come based on our
missing mandatory data in stages
system exceptions will occur based on
internet is down
or robot need internet or any system
failures
business exceptions these exceptions are
not actually exceptions
however based on the business rules we
are creating the exceptions
we need to fire manually through bot
work queues
our queue is a list that may be
configured internally to help a process
manage its workload
a process may use numerous work use and
a work view may be shared by multiple
processes
if necessary the control room queue
management tab
serves as the operational user interface
for work use
the tab is divided into two sections
the upper half displays a list of queues
while the lower half displays a list of
queue items
in the configuration of work u work
views are formed in the blue prism's
administrative area system manager
now let us look at a demo on email
automation
if you haven't installed a blue prism
software yet then check out our video on
blue prism installation
and get it installed so let's jump into
blue prism
software and get started with the email
automation
let's first sign in blue prism
click on next this is the overview about
the home page
studio and control room and digital
exchange
close it let's go to studio
the very first step is to import email
pop3
smtp business object to import that go
to file
go to import process object
and go to browse you have to go to the
folder where blue prism software is
installed
in my device it's installed in c
go to local disk c go to program files
and go to blue prism limited
blueprism automate here scroll down
and go to vbo business objects
and here you can see email pop3
smtp select click on open select this
and click on open and click on
next
click on next
click on next
so when you're done with this the email
pop3 smtp
will be imported the next thing is
create a new process so select process
go to create new process and let's name
the process
we'll name the process as
email automation
click on next enter a description of
this process
if you want so that if some other user
opens the file
he should know that what is the process
about so enter the description
it's optional so we'll click on finish
and let's open this process now
the very first step is to drag and drop
and action so select action and drop it
here
open this action
so in first step we will set up the
email of the smtp
business object so we'll name it as name
this action as setup
select the business object as email pop3
smtp
and the action is configure we are
configuring it
and here we have to enter the username
password of the server
details so from where do we get the
server details
to get the server details we have to go
to the browser
go to the browser and
search as gmail server configuration
here you see you will get the all the
details here
the port number the email
so in the smtp server we'll enter the
smtp.gmail.com and the port number as
587
and in the pop3 we will enter pop
gmail.com and port number as 995
and both the servers will turn it on
to turn it on we'll write it as true
so we'll go back to the blue prism
so enter the server
pop.gmail.com enter it in the double
quotes
an smtp server enter as smtp
not gmail.com
and the pop report number is 995.
and the smtp port number is 587
and pop use ssl should turn it on to
turn
it on we need to enter the value as true
okay now we should enter the username
and password
if i enter the password here for example
if i enter the password here the
password is visible
we don't want the password to be visible
the password should be encrypted
so for the password to be encrypted in
data item there is an option called
passwording data types
so go to data item
drag and drop a data item
and select the data type as password
and enter the password here here the
password will be
encrypted
and click on ok
we'll name the data item as password
similarly we will use another data item
for username
name the data item as username select
the data type as
text and give the initial value
so enter your email id
and click on ok so now we have username
and password
now go to the setup and select the
username and password
drag and drop this username
and in the passwords drag and drop the
password
so so the setup is done
the next step is
the next step is we want to enter the
subject and the data in the mail
right for that we need to use another
action
item drag and drop another action
name it as sending message
select the business object as email pop
sm
tp
and go to action and in the action
select the action as send message
here you need to enter the email id to
whom you want to send so i'll enter the
email id which we had entered in the
username
enter both the from and to email ids so
i'll use the same email id
since this is just for demo i'm using
the same email id
so enter the subject subject i'll enter
it as
demo and enter the body
hello
so now that we have entered the subject
and body let's
close this and now let us
now use the link and connect it
now let us click on run and check
whether we have received the
email
oops there is an error we have missed
something
oh we have missed a double quote
let us save again
reset and run
so the process is completed let us go to
the email
inbox and check whether we have received
the email
so let me refresh and here you go
we have received the email
as hello and the subject is demo
so we have received the email now let us
send it with an
attachment so for that you go to the
blue prism
we go to sending message here here you
can see attachment
attachment is of the data type
collection
right so for that we need to use a
collection
item so drag and drop a collection
go to collections and
click on import select the business
object
as email and select the action
as send message and the parameter with
attachments select the attachment and
click on ok
next go to initial value in initial
value click on add
you can add multiple path here and
attach how many other
attachments you want for now we'll
attach only one attachment
so you need to provide the file path
here so
we'll go to the desktop so i have this
article
on desktop so i'll attach this article
in the email
so select this article
shift and right click and copy as
path copy this path go back to blue
prism
and provide the path here
remove the double quotes
and click on ok
so once the collection item is completed
go back to sending message
go to collections here in the collection
select this
and click on ok
click on reset and let us run
and here you go you can see the process
is completed
so let us go to the email inbox and
check if we have received an email with
an attachment
so here we go we have received the email
with the attachment
let us open it the same email with the
subject demo
and the body as hello and with the
article which i had attached
rpa projects so i have received the
attachment if you are planning to attend
an interview for an rpa
or blueprism developer role here is a
comprehensive list of the most
frequently asked
blue prism interview questions with
answers we will first look at the
beginner level interview questions
what is blue prism blue prism is a
software that develops enterprise
robotic process automation
allowing businesses to automate complex
end-to-end operations
blueprism developed the virtual
workforce platform concept
and works on the enterprise robotic
process automation platform that is
strong
highly scalable secure and reliable
blueprism software complements standard
it solutions by utilizing an
agile virtual workforce that follows
rule-based business process
and interacts with system the same way
users do
blue prisms rpa software solution
automates tasks that would otherwise be
carried out manually
by humans or through significant
customization of current id systems
which would result in a higher level of
automation with significantly lesser
investment and faster deployment
explain the different types of tabs in
blue prism dashboard
there are six types of tabs in blue
prism the first tab is
home the homepage includes many charts
that provide information on the
blueprism database
blueprism studio is a critical component
through which we build actual automation
actions
with studio we can automate a process
build a process using flow
add logic calculations and intelligence
without writing any code we can also
drag in actions calculations
loops and more in studio we can connect
the blocks in preferred order
we can use intelligent skills from
digital exchange
the studios are divided into two
categories object studio
and process studio control room
the control room is the key
administrative point in blue prism
where it handles the control monitoring
execution
and scheduling of process executions on
dispersed bots
the control room assigns the processes
to digital workers
users can quickly start a process by
dragging it onto a resource
analytics blueprism analytics is a
module
that allows you to see data graphically
in the form of charts
such as pie chart bar chart column gauge
and line
releases the release manager is used to
manage configuration package
import and export between multiple
blueprism settings
system administrators use the system tab
to manage users
explain the features of blue prism
provides intelligent execution
technology organizations
can instruct the autonomous engine on
process priorities
feed amounts of work and leave it to run
without human involvement
responding to systems business scenario
and change in priority
robots like humans can be used to do
tasks based on sla volume
and priority and adjust and change robot
allocation dynamically without human
intervention
high security a software robot securely
locks into an application and
manipulates the presentation layer in
the same manner a person would
but in a controlled non-invasive
environment ensuring that the
application's integrity is never
affected
on premises or in the cloud on-premises
or hybrid enterprise deployment
provisioned in a public or a private
cloud the robots are existing and
running
any operation set in blue prism can be
conducted on
any number of robots in the virtual
workforce
microsoft sql server blue prism is built
on microsoft.net framework
it is technologically flexible working
across the other platforms
and technologies such as a mainframe
windows app wpf
app java sap exchange and many more
scalability blueprism is object oriented
allowing for a rapid scalability
by utilizing reusable items and
libraries
analytics and reporting provides high
quality data that can be used to
produce relevant bi and mi reporting and
provide in-line process statistics and
real-time operational insights by
capturing each step
work queues work use provides a
q-centric approach for dynamically
controlling the number of resources
or robots operating against a given
queue at any given time
what is a process studio the process
studio is created as a diagram that
looks much like a common business flow
diagram
process studio allows the company rit to
design
build edit and test process made out of
reusable blue prism elements
as the library of business object grows
actions can be scheduled and controlled
in the process layer
the top tier of the blue prism
architecture process studio provides a
similar interface to object studio
and allows you to sequence and test
business logic control loops variables
and
object calls in visible business flow
what is object studio object studio is
the design canvas on which blue prism
robot is programmed to conduct the
fundamental system activities
that serve as a foundation of process
the presentation layer which provides a
library of
elements to operate quickly models and
validates the target desktop application
we have several types of activities
within the object such as modular
application to spy the elements
initialize page and cleanup page
what is control room in blue prism
control room allows businesses or id
services to schedule perform and control
processes
blue prism platform administrators use
the control room interface to monitor
and review the status of connected
runtime resources in the production
environment
the interface also allows for manual
process start and stop
automated process schedule settings and
extensive management information
and dig downs into blueprism task queues
in production environment
process are run from a control room from
control room
processors do not run on a version of
blue prism that is local to your desktop
but is instead run on an external
resource known as digital workers
which can be found in the resource area
what is the environment variable the
environment variable is a type of
exposure in data item
in which data item value is easily
changed without using the processor
object
it is available in the system tab under
the process section
which are the data types available in
blue prism
data items can store a range of data
types though each data item within a
process must be assigned
a specific data type to store the data
types available in blue prism
are as follows date flag date
time number text password
time image and binary
explain weight stage wait stage enables
business objects to pause and wait for
an application to load
or a condition to be met before
continuing
weight conditions can be applied to
weight stages to evaluate whether a
condition exists within a specific
period
the weight condition produces a flag
value determining which of the two
branches
the logic will flow down it is best to
include a conditional wage state at the
start of every object diagram
it is possible to set multiple weight
conditions for a weight stage
by adding additional rows into the
action area
the weight stage simultaneously checks
each weight condition it doesn't require
all weight conditions to be met even if
one condition is met the path will be
determined
if none of the weight conditions are met
the action will time out
explain the benefits of blue prism
automated speed
days and weeks to automate a process in
blue prism that would take months and
years to automate using a standard
automation methodologies
less expense robots are programmed with
the business rules of repetitive
clerical duties
and deployed to drive existing
applications eliminating the requirement
for costly integration and process
redesign expertise
improved performance a small specialist
ability within the it department
collaborates with the robotic workforce
to train them manage referrals and
continuously enhance their operational
performance
secure the robotic automation platform
is secure
audited and governed within the
governance iit corridor
the usage of software robots invariably
increases
compliance with applicable data
standards and confidentiality
scalable because the software robots
operate in a virtualized environment
they can be rapidly scaled up and down
based on the demand
what is exceptional handling in blue
prism
exceptional handling is critical part of
any blue prism solution
an exception is a problem that arises
during the execution of a process
or an object when errors are encountered
in blue prism it generates exceptions
the managing of exceptions in unattended
automation is defined as exception
handling
it ensures that defaults can be
automatically fixed if possible
or that they are easily identified
repairable by a system administrators
or that they can be forwarded for human
completion if necessary
exception handling success is determined
by how well it is implemented throughout
the development phase
explain the different stages of
exception handling the different stages
of exceptional handling are
recovery resume and exception in
recovery stage
begins a block for handling exceptions
in resume stage it ends a block for
handling exceptions
in exception stage explicitly arises an
exception in the execution of a process
or an object
explain the applications of blue prism
blue blueprism's rps software is used in
the following process types
rules based processing using a
structured digital inputs such as credit
card activation or fraud detection
transactional processing that is
repeated such as sim swaps or invoicing
processing
transaction quantities that are high
such as building or new handset order
processing
issues with process address quality such
as policy renewals or policy migrations
complex mission critical procedures such
as pension redemptions
and financial reconciliation
changes in demand or backlogs such as
new product launches
use in hr onboarding are the
introduction of new online product where
no
integration exists
now let us look at the intermediate
level interview questions
what is an application modeler which are
the different types of spying modes
present in it
a business object aims to integrate with
an application
to make the business accessible for use
by a blue prism process to create the
integration you must connect the
business object to the application
by creating an application modeler this
can be achieved via application modeler
within the object studio
the process of creating a logical
representation of an application
by identifying and capturing elements
from the user interface of the
application
is called spying the four different
types of spying modes
are as follows win32 mode html mode
accessibility mode and region mode
explain circular paths in blue prism
blue prism is designed to automate
repetitive work and inclusion of
circular paths
looping process diagrams enables some
steps to be repeated over and over again
components that are essential for
building circular path
which will allow a process flow to loop
through
then progress to the end once the loop
limit is met
components that are essential for
building a circular path which will
allow a process flow to loop through
then process to the end once the loop
limit is met
explain the types of exceptions in blue
prism
the three types of exceptions in blue
prism are internal exception
internal exceptions come based on our
missing mandatory data in stages
system exceptions these exceptions will
occur based on the internet is down
or our bot needs internet or any system
failures
business exceptions these exceptions are
not really exceptions
they are based on the business rules we
are creating the exceptions
we need to fire manually through the bot
what are work use our queue is a list
that may be configured internally to
help a process manage its workload
a process may use numerous work use and
work you may be shared by multiple
processes if necessary
work queues are created and configured
in the workflow area of system manager
this is where work use can be provided
with a name and a key name
the key name directly correlates to a
column name in the collection stage
used within a process to add new items
to a work queue
explain the stages in process studio
decision stage decision stage have two
branches coming out of them
enabling a process to split into two
separate paths
they are used to evaluate the result of
an expression as either true or
false in blue prism these outcomes are
known as flags
calculation stage calculation stage
use expressions to calculate values
these can be numerical or made using
values such as
text dates etc
they are dependent on data items to
store results and can work with data
items to perform calculations
data items data item acts as a
placeholder for values
such as numbers text and dates
they can give a meaningful names like
username
email id and employed around the process
diagram data item is like a variable
explain process validation
the validation button opens the process
validation window for diagnosing
issues the validation window categorizes
issues as errors
warning and advice it identifies the
type of action that should be taken to
resolve them
and whether they are repairable by blue
prism
validation checks the basic construction
of process diagram
but it is not capable of analyzing the
logic the responsibility is always on
the user
explain collections and loops in blue
prism
collection stage provides process
diagram the ability to hold multiple
values together
the values stored within the collection
states are accessed one row at a time
using a loop stage to move forward
through the rows
loop stages is divided into two parts
loop start and loop end
explain business objects the purpose of
business object is to provide an
interface to capture the functionality
of an application
business objects are used as a part of
process solution
and can be thought of as a separate
layer of process the tasks within a
business objects are separated out in
different pages
known as actions each action relates to
a particular interaction with an
application
and a process will use whichever of this
action it requires
in any order to perform a specific task
within the application
explain the difference between process
and object studio
in process studio the development tool
creates a diagram
that resembles a flow diagram object
studio
creates objects graphically by the
development tool
process studio has alert stage only
object studio has
read write navigate code and wait stage
process studio consists of main page
only
object studio consists of initialize and
cleanup page
resource studio interacts with the
object studio and control room
object studio interacts with external
applications
launch and application modeler is not
available in process studio
but whereas in object studio it is
available
explain throttles and unconditional
weights in blue prism
wage stages can be used without any
conditions
with the timeout serving as a pause to
delay the flow through the diagram
this is referred as throttling
throttling allows some extra time to
accommodate the variable performance
speed of an application
it is best practice to include
throttling at the beginning of every
action page
that interacts within the application
explain the input and output parameters
in blueprism
input and output parameters are used to
transmit values between the process
diagram and the business object
action business objects any value that
is required to input into the elements
of an application
should be passed down from a process via
an input parameter the business object
should only retain the information
passed down to it
for as long as it takes to complete the
interaction
an end stage on the lower page can use
output parameters to transmit a value
up to a page reference stage on an upper
page
now let us look at some of the advanced
level blue prism interview questions
what is a scheduler and how to configure
it
the blue prism tool allows to execute
process at a specified times
and repeat their execution at different
intervals it is termed as scheduler
the blue prism tool allows you to run
process at a specific times
and repeat them at different intervals
this is known as scheduler
configure schedules are in the system
tab by clicking on the scheduler option
after we configure the scheduler we need
to click on the check box
to activate it
explain release manager in blue prism
blueprism release manager enables users
to compile all of the components of a
blue prism solution into a package
including processors business objects
and work use
as schedules calendars tiles and
dashboards
to export a solution package a release
must be created by right clicking
package overview and selecting new
package a release is a snapshot of a
state of each of the components within a
package
at a particular moment in time
how to create object in object studio
here are the steps to create object in
object studio
launch the blue prism software and open
the studio tab
right click on the objects and select
create object
then enter a name for new business
object enter the description which is
optional
and finally it will create an object in
objects list
so let's jump into blueprism software
and create object
so after launching the blueprism
software
go to studio
go to objects right click objects and
click on create object
enter the name of the object so i'll
enter
object demo
after entering the name click on next
and enter the description
which is optional and click on finish
and here you can see the object is
created in the object list
that is how you create an object in the
object studio
explain the concept of exceptional
bubbling since
exceptions can occur at any point
throughout a process solution
whenever an exception occurs it will
always move up towards the main page of
the process to the highest layer of the
process solution
an exception will continue to bubble up
from an action in business
object and then through the hierarchy of
pages within the calling process
until it reaches the page that contains
a recovery logic at this point the
exception will be handled
if the main page of the highest layer of
the process solution
does not have logic to handle the error
then an error message window will appear
when running in process studio
the same error occurs when running a
process in control room the process will
terminate
how to import vbo in blue prism
the first step is go to blue prism
studio and click on file
and click on import then the import
release dialog box opens
click on browse navigate to program
files in c
drive in program files go to blue prism
limited
then to blue prism automate and open
vbevo
from there you can double click and
select the object
demonstrate the working of an email
automation in blue prism
first we'll create a new process then
we'll perform some of the actions
in which we will use action stage data
item and collection stage
then after performing all the required
actions finally we will go to our
mail inbox and check if we have received
the mail
so we will jump into blue prism software
and see how to import and bbo in blue
prism
and see the working of email automation
in blue prism
let's go to studio
the very first step is to import email
pop3
smdp business object to import that go
to file
go to import process object
and go to browse you have to go to the
folder where blue prism software is
installed
in my device it's installed in c
go to local disk c go to program files
and go to blue prism limited
blueprism automate here scroll down
and go to vbo business objects
and here you can see email pop3 smtp
select click on open select this
and click on open and click on
next
click on next
click on next
so when you're done with this the email
pop3 smtp will be imported
the next thing is create a new process
so select process go to create new
process
and let's name the process
we'll name the process as
email automation
click on next enter a description of
this process
if you want so that if some other user
opens the file
he should know that what is the process
about so enter the description
it's optional so we'll click on finish
and let's open this process now
the very first step is to drag and drop
and action so select action and drop it
here
open this action
so in first step we will set up the
email of the smtp
business object so we'll name it as name
this action as setup
select the business object as email pop3
smtp
and the action is configure we are
configuring it
and here we have to enter the username
password of the server
details so from where do we get the
server details
to get the server details we have to go
to the browser
go to the browser and
search as gmail server configuration
here you see you will get the all the
details here
the port number the email
so in the smtp server we'll enter the
smtp.gmail.com and the port number as
587
and in the pop3 we will enter pop
gmail.com and port number as 995
and both the servers will turn it on
to turn it on we'll write it as true
so we'll go back to the blueprism
so enter the server
pop.gmail.com enter it in the double
quotes
an smtp server enter as smtp
not gmail.com
and the pop report number is 995
and the smtp port number is 587
and pop use ssl should turn it on to
turn it on you need to enter the value
as
true
okay now we should enter the username
and password
if i enter the password here for example
if i enter the password here the
password is visible
we don't want the password to be visible
the password should be encrypted
so for the password to be encrypted in
data item there is an option called
passwording data types
so go to data item
drag and drop a data item
and select the data type as password
and enter the password here here the
password will be
encrypted
and click on ok
will name the data item as password
similarly we will use another data item
for username
name the data item as username select
the data type as
text and give the initial value
so enter your email id
and click on ok so now we have username
and password
now go to the setup and select the
username and password
drag and drop this username
and in the passwords drag and drop the
password
so so the setup is done
the next step is
the next step is we want to enter the
subject and the data in the mail
right for that we need to use another
action
item drag and drop another action
name it as sending message
select the business object as email pop
sm
dp
and go to action and in the action
select the action as send message
here you need to enter the email id to
whom you want to send
so i'll enter the email id which we had
entered in the username
enter both the from and to email ids so
i'll use the same email id
since this is just for demo i'm using
the same email id
so enter the subject subject i'll enter
it as
demo and enter the body
hello
so now that we have entered the subject
and body let's close this
and now let us now use the link
and connect it
now let us click on run and check
whether we have received the
email
oops there is an error we have missed
something
oh we have missed the double quote
let us save again
reset and run
so the process is completed let us go to
the email
inbox and check whether we have received
the email
so let me refresh and here we go
we have received the email
as hello and the subject is demo
so we have received the email now let us
send it with an
attachment so for that we go to the blue
prism
we go to sending message here here you
can see attachment
attachment is of the data type
collection
right so for that we need to use a
collection
item so drag and drop a collection
go to collections and
click on import select the business
object
as email and select the action
as send message and the parameter
with attachments select the attachment
and click on ok next go to initial value
in initial value click on add you can
add multiple
path here and attach how many other
attachments you want
for now we'll attach only one attachment
so you need to provide the
file path here so we'll go to the
desktop
so i have this article on desktop so
i'll attach this article in the email
so select this article
shift and right click and copy
as path copy this path go back to blue
prism
and provide the path here
remove the double quotes
and click on ok
so once the collection item is completed
go back to sending message
go to collections here in the collection
select this
and click on ok
click on reset and let us
run
and here you go you can see the process
is completed so let us go to the email
inbox
and check if we have received an email
with an attachment
so here we go we have received the email
with the attachment
let us open it the same email with the
subject demo
and the body as hello and with the
article which i had
attached rpa projects so i have received
the
attachment so with that we have come to
end of this blue prism full course
if you enjoyed watching it make sure to
hit the subscribe button
and press the bell icon to never miss an
update thank you so much for being here
watch out for more videos from us until
then keep learning and stay tuned to
simply learn
you